well let's take a look at what is likely
to happen this week if Parliament votes
against trees a maize deal on Tuesday
afternoon and she'll have a maximum of
three days to set out a course of action
she could attempt to renegotiate her
deal with the EU and that could require
extending article 50 which would need to
be agreed by all EU countries and would
delay Britain's exit from the EU she
doesn't do this the UK could default to
a No Deal brexit on March the 29th
leaving without agreement however more
than 220 MPs have indicated their desire
to stop No Deal breaks it happening and
some would almost certainly push
alternative plans while all this is
taking place labour indicated that they
are likely to propose a vote of no
confidence in the government if this
motion is passed there will be a 14 day
period in which a government must win
the support of majority of MPs in the
House of Commons in a new confidence
vote this could be a Conservative
government led by Therese in May or a
successor or and if they were to win the
Conservatives could stay in power but
Jeremy Corbyn might get the chance to
form a government if he was able to
command enough MPs to support it and if
neither of these things were to happen
within the 14 day period a general
election would automatically be
triggered and if the initial
no-confidence motion were defeated
however labour may then table a motion
calling for a people's vote or a second
referendum